did you know there's an 18 mile long
string of wire circling the island of
Manhattan every morning the wire is
checked for breaks and snags and every
day it's repaired and it cost about a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year to maintain the wire has been there
for years yet most New Yorkers myself
included didn't even know it was there
let's find out why
[Music]
to understand why there's an 18 mile
long wire going around New York City we
need a quick lesson about Judaism the
Sabbath begins every Friday night at
Sunset and goes all the way through
Saturday and Jewish people who observed
the Sabbath Saturday is a day of rest
meaning you don't work at all and work
doesn't just mean your job work is
defined as any activity that was
necessary in the building of the
Tabernacle now that might sound like
just construction work is forbidden but
it's actually much more obviously no
building of any kind is permitted but
also no grinding baking sowing even
starting a fire not even small tasks
like tying tearing or putting finishing
touches on objects oh and also no
electricity on the Sabbath you set up
all these rules God why doesn't God want
you to do any of this stuff on Saturday
well because he feels you should have
one day a week to engage in pleasurable
activities like eating spending time
with family and having sex she bad
sounds pretty good actually it can be
but on Saturday there's one tricky rule
no carrying anything from a domestic
area to a public area you can't carry
anything nope no wallet no keys No
carrying or pushing your children in a
stroller nothing like that you can carry
these things within your home but not
outside and that's where the wire comes
in yeah I don't follow well stick around
and I'll tell you no a cliffhanger
[Music]
what what the heck is this Shabbat
sounds like a really good idea so I'm
show me Shabbos you're Shoma Shabbos
show mashabas you can't just put on a
hat
okay okay take it easy
anyway on the Sabbath you can carry
things within your home so grabbing a
glass of water from the kitchen is fine
but you can't carry anything from your
home to a public place now this is
tricky if you want to leave your house
and lock the door behind you you aren't
permitted to carry your keys and what if
you have an infant you can't carry a
child or even push a stroller and if you
need a cane to walk no can do and if you
think this sounds inconvenient you're
not the only one many years ago rabbis
realized that in order to fully enjoy
the Sabbath you sometimes needed to
carry things and this is where the wire
around New York comes in it's called an
a-roove and an a-roove is an unbroken
continuous string or wire that circles a
large public area now originally a
Reuben were actual walls but now there's
some solid walls and anything within the
borders of the arub is now considered
part of the domestic domain which means
if you want to carry on Saturday as long
as you're within the a roof you're good
to go you're very rich fish
all day long
if ever a wealthy feeling
in the 1990s there were only a few
aravan in the United States but now
there are hundreds if you live in a
medium-sized City there's probably an a
roof or two in your neighborhood and if
you live in a big city there's
definitely at least one the most
expensive Arab in the world and the one
with the largest population is the mayor
of in Manhattan and it began as a small
community enclosure in the upper west
side and now it covers almost the entire
island of Manhattan what area is in
coving Hell's Kitchen checks out every
morning a rabbi drives the entire length
of the wire and notes places where it
could be broken then on Thursday and
Friday he goes out with a construction
team to make sure the wire is repaired
and it costs about 150 000 a year to
maintain this the Manhattan neighborhood
has survived vandalism to hurricanes
even one really aggressive Thanksgiving
Day float damn you SpongeBob it's had a
couple of close calls but for over 20
years the a-roove has remained intact so
there's an almost invisible wire running
around almost every major city in the
western world including 18 miles around
Manhattan Island
and now you know why
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's Heckle
fish this has been the y-files if you
had fun or learned anything do me a
favor and comment like subscribe and
share and until next time be safe be
kind and know that you
you're stepping on my outro oh calm down
I will not calm down I'm trying to thank
people for watching the episode and
you're over here
[Music]
thank you